[Music]
hello there
it's update time once again in fortnite
can you believe
it's week five of season six chapter two
already
here's a random fact it's been 1 350
days since the whole battle royale
fortnite thing began if you're new
around here this is the series in which
we look at the map updates and newly
added core challenges to uncover
more about the storyline of fortnite and
hopefully
predict the future what will happen next
so sit your butt down for between five
to ten minutes
slap code adamaru in to support my
nonsense and
let's go through all the changes in the
new update
hud watch over to the sheriff after the
events of the zero point story the sand
dunes the sheriff once called home were
no more and deadshot was forced to find
a new home
he chose this spot outside lazy lake
in week one it was simply a campsite
with few ways to identify it would
change but then look at week three he
made the building frame and began to
upgrade
to what we have today and here it is a
completed sheriff's office
upstairs has a nice wardrobe and writing
desk combo
and there's a deer's head on the wall if
you're into that kind of thing
downstairs things are complete here too
two jail cells
ready for outlaws oh and there's graham
i wonder what he did wrong
will we ever find out as this place is
now complete i guess hot watch for the
season
is over so one last time
the biggest update of the week are tires
and no not the ones around your mum
we can now apply new wheels to our rides
at various places around the island
pleasant park is the one advertised in
the trailer but these places have sprung
up everywhere there is a gas station
over at the superstore with the viking
boat on top of it a new garage
now stands opposite the garage by
slurpee is now upgraded
as is the one at the dam and 20 sands
and caddy corner
basically all of them you get the drift
oh and even at lazy lake
it's this building here so now there is
no excuse not to go
off-road in fact did you see the trailer
there is something we have to test right
away
the 30 second clip tells us we can climb
the face of a mountain in our new
off-road tyres so we gotta try it here's
what happens with a standard off-road
vehicle with standard road tyres
it's a great effort but it's not getting
up mount gate
so the same vehicle the same mountain
but with new off-road tyres
here we go okay so it's definitely
improving
but still not possible for the final
test i grabbed the fastest car i could
and threw on those tires and raced up
the mountain
i used the inbuilt boost and look what
[Music]
happened
it is indeed possible to drive up a
mountain but it's not totally because of
those tyres
[Music]
our next update is extremely missable
get your butt over to any of the raptor
egg locations
and you'll see something new what the
heck is this
some sort of vial or sample well have
you played a game called horizon zero
dawn this thing
is a blaze canister these are all over
the dino egg locations but as we know
those already hatched so this must
confirm the addition of eli from horizon
zero dawn
if you don't have a clue who that is
it's all good the game will be free on
playstation next week
and if you're not a playstation gamer
don't worry i made a story video if
you'd like to know all about the girl
who fights robot dinosaurs does this
mean we could get robot dinosaurs
in fortnite to fight the primal dinos no
okay i'll i'll shut up let's move on to
the law
the core narrative is slowly becoming
visible in game
this week it's the spire talking to us
let's just backtrack a week for a moment
last time we spoke many npcs told us
that the primal biome
is spreading like a corruption and
approaching the modern areas of the
island
since we last met the inhabitants of
pleasant park set up a barricade
others have since followed suit misty
meadows was the first to build a barrier
between
itself and the nearest spire vehicles
boardings
atm machines railings anything they
could get their hands on to make a
makeshift
barrier then the people at retail row
became the next to act
using the same system to keep the
corruption at bay here there is also a
watch post set up keeping an eye
straight on that spire that outpost just
to the north
and also graham got out of prison look
he's here nice mask bro
the next day the next community acted
this time at 20 sans
this is definitely building to something
as today the barrier there got a little
bit higher
sandbags are now stacked on the beach
ready for the approaching corruption
of the primal age which leads us nicely
onto the spires this week
in game right now raz has a new mission
for us to look over the strange magic
at the guardian outposts and using this
weird ass piece of kit
play the spires message and here it is
you hear it he says jonesy knows and
that was the voice of rock the dwayne
johnson the foundation the dude
stuck in the chrome testicle the man in
the zero point
he's using the outposts to talk to us
telling us to speak to the johnsy
snapshots
and for this quest we need to speak to
five different variants of johnsy
here's the ones i spoke to cabbie johnsy
says
me working with the foundation not
likely
that guy is just waiting for an excuse
to kick my
weight how do you know about the
foundation also how do
i know about the foundation this loop
does strange things to your memory
so we can confirm that memories are
coming back to the npcs
over at sweaty sands suntan jonesy says
right on man
i always thought i'd be a hero but if i
knew me i probably don't want
to be stuck in a weird limbo between
worlds maybe one of the other joneses
can help
this johnsy turned us down and tells us
about an in-between limbo world
is that what we're on right now or is
that something to look forward to in the
future
wreck raider points out that the zero
point looping causes echoes and he
doesn't know why
castaway johnsy is shocked to find out
there are more johnsies but he's only
interested in if they have food for him
or not
and finally i went to visit rex who says
you needed a johnsy
and you came to me look at me you know
why i'm dressed like a dinosaur
because i sure don't those are only five
of the joneses that i saw
if you speak to someone different could
you please take a screenshot and send it
to me on twitter
i'd like to piece together everything
that he said and i know there's a lot of
stuff we can throw to the side but
occasionally one of these johnsies
say something full of law and i'd like
to try and get them all together
finally we are sent to speak to jonesy
the first over at pleasant park
we must then battle him to get him on
our side once that's done and we return
he gives us some more law there are
people who think the spire will make
them powerful
it will but it will also exploit their
every weakness now here's the bit to
remember
do not allow the spire to corrupt
someone powerful or jones does not stand
a chance
now go before the spire attracts any
more from the
and he stops talking there is jones
talking about the io the imagined order
the runes on the spires do link to their
logo what's your guess
so let's summarize all the story content
the foundation has found a way to
communicate with us from inside the
spire zero point
using the outposts telling us jonesy
knows we then talked to various
snapshots until jonesy the first
told us about the corruption and if the
power falls into the wrong hands
the story will end badly for josie
if i had to guess i'd say razz may be
that individual
looking to harness the power of the
spire and i talk about him
in this video i'll link it so i don't go
over old content
so how did i do this week did i miss
anything please let me know and i'll
include it next time i'm adam from
playstation grenade thank you for your
time and a huge thanks if you used code
adamarrow this week
like these legends thanks for supporting
me really appreciate it
see you next time
[Music]
you